اضافته الاوكرانيه على ارض المعركه
يتوقفوا على شحنات الاسلحه الغربيه التي
سيتم ارسالها الى كيف في الاشهر المقبله
وفي وقت لا تزال مقاتلات الاف 16
الامريكيه والدبابات الالمانيه ضمن قائمه
الاسلحه المطلوبه شملت القائمه خطوط حمراء
عده كذلك حيث يشدد مسؤولون اوكرانيون على
ضروره التزود بالصواريخ طويله المدى
ومدرعات ودبابات قتال حديثه لترسيخ التفوق
وانهاء الصراع
فبحسب العسكريين صواريخ جافلن ورجمات
صواريخ هاي مارس اثبتت دقيقتها في استهداف
المواقع الروسيه لكن القوات الروسيه تكيفت
مع هذا التهديد وفقا تعبيرهم واضافوا ان
رؤوس نقل مراكز القياده ومستودعات الاسلحه
من نطاق 80 ميلان من بطاريات هاي مارس الى
نطاق ابعد لكن معسكرات معسكرات الجنود
الروس ونقاط تم ركزهم بقيت في نطاق مرمى
صواريخ هاي مارس ودليل على فعاليتها سقوط
عشرات الجنود الروس في دوناتس في اربع
صواريخ من طراز هاي مارس
هذه التحركات والنتائج الايجابيه على
الميدان زادت الدعوات الاوكرانيه لتزويدهم
بصواريخ
وهي اطول مده من نظراتها هاي مارس والتي
يمكنها التحليق طويلا بقطعها مسافه تتجاوز
190 ميلان قبل ان تصيب الهدف بدقه